every day things happen that change the
way the world looks
most days it changes in subtle ways that
go unnoticed
on other days on more rare days things
happen that change it in dramatic
noticeable ways changes that turn the
world upside down
and make it so the world of yesterday
doesn't even recognize the world of
today
on june 2nd 1993 a girl named christy
lyanna was born
she was born to a fairly typical middle
class american family but she was
anything but fairly typical
almost immediately christie showed signs
of uniqueness and high intelligence
before age one she was able to form
sentences and solve difficult problems
on her own at three months old she
figured out how to open the baby proof
latch on her crib and move freely around
the house when no one was paying
attention
surprising her father one night when he
found her in the living room watching tv
on her own
christy's parents quickly realized how
special she was and knew she would grow
up to do something incredible
they told little christy that she was
going to grow up and change the world
as christy grew older and started school
she was almost immediately treated
differently by her peers and teachers
as they found her intelligence to be
intimidating and freakish
starting in kindergarten she grew almost
every grade in every school practically
as soon as she started
her teachers would tell her how
incredible she was and that she was
destined to change the world and that
she was too smart for their classroom
and perhaps their grade in general
christie would end up jumping around to
a couple different schools until she
finally found a program that could
handle her intellect
once situated in a school for gifted
children like herself she would carry
out her education
and obtain incredible achievements as
christie flew through elementary school
into high school and then college
she would graduate each stage of
education multiple years ahead of the
norm
acquiring an ivy league undergraduate
degree by 15 years old
and a master's degree in computer
science by 17. throughout her education
she would do profound things far ahead
of her age and was requested to appear
on national tv several times for her
accomplishments
it was inevitable to everyone that she
would go on to do something incredible
and change the world while she was
receiving her master's degree
christie's father was diagnosed with
stage four lung cancer
over the several months following the
diagnosis christie watched her father
with her down in pain
she had never felt so helpless and
tormented she wanted to help her father
she began to research and talk with
professors in a desperate attempt to see
if there was anything she could do in
the small window of time she had
her father died not long after the
diagnosis long before christie could do
anything
the pain she felt from her father's
death would inevitably change the course
of her future
the course of everyone's future the
cancer research and effort she made
during her father's final months would
ignite her career
guiding her decisions for how she would
attempt to in fact change the world
she realized in this experience of pain
and more importantly the pain she
witnessed her father experience
she would do everything in her power to
rid the world of such pain to rid the
world of disease
early death and suffering altogether to
create a world that's an ideal utopic
version of itself
she believed there was a future where
this could exist having left her mark on
so many important members of the ivy
league community during her time in
school
as well as receiving substantial awards
and achievements christy was sought out
by leading research
tech and software companies following
graduation
she went on to work for several
companies in the medical sector and she
soon found herself pursuing research and
software development in the genetic
engineering space
specifically in terms of removing
viruses from patients with existing dna
sequence mutations
as well as encoding newborns with genes
to have immunities to major diseases
at this time in history this space was
the next big wave in medical research
and technology
researchers and companies were racing to
make the next big discovery
and find safe predictable ways to edit
genetic code and alter people's
biologies
however at the time christie only had so
much control over the decision-making in
the company she worked with
and felt that decisions were often made
poorly and money and focus were often
put on the wrong things
and so in her late 20s christie decided
she would start her own medical software
company
several years later at age 32 in the
year 2025
christie and her company would develop
software that could assist in safe
highly predictable genetic engineering
christie would be responsible for
creating an algorithm-driven simulation
software that could accurately model
test and predict
the effects of specific dna editing in
specific individuals
what had previously been highly risky
and complicated was now
fully accessible genetic information
could be mapped with extreme detail
and the effects of genetic modifications
could be accurately predicted
holistically
generations into the future ensuring
that manipulations could be executed
properly and safely
with this genetic engineering could
begin to permeate commonplace medical
practice
disease treatment and human childbearing
in a short time following
cancer and many other major diseases
would be eradicated newborns would be
encoded in ways so that all dispositions
to physical ailments disabilities and
diseases would be eliminated as well as
all dispositions to mental disorders
following that genetic engineering would
begin to eliminate dispositions towards
things like high-level violence
aggression
depression and anxiety during this time
there were massive worldwide debates
regarding the regulations on what should
be allowed to be manipulated but with
christie's technology
agreements and systems could be made
much more efficiently and genetic
engineering would soon become the norm
not too long after the technology's
implementation christie would be
recognized publicly as one of the most
intelligent and impactful members of
modern humanity
and for many of all of history she was
awarded the nobel prize as well as
innumerable other awards accolades and
social recognitions
she had the brilliance the discipline
the virtuous social
and moral intention the patience and the
successful execution
she dedicated her life to this she
sacrificed her youth her young adulthood
and her middle adulthood
she worked non-stop she had no social
life and now she did it
she changed the world forever just how
she wanted to just how she was told she
was supposed to
50 years later the world had gone
through about two generations with
christie's technology and the world's
illness and disease rates were at an
all-time low
mental health was at an all-time high
the average lifespan was rapidly
increasing
people were being born with exceptional
talents and physical complexions
incredible things were happening peace
and cooperation were blossoming across
the planet in a way humanity had never
seen
christie was witnessing her impact
unfold into a perfect utopic world
just as she had intended 100 more years
and four more generations would go by
it's the year 2177 lifespans are into
the hundreds and predicted to continue
into the low thousands
suicide rates are the highest ever in
history
having been encoded with specific traits
and skills people find it increasingly
difficult to find any meaning in their
lives
knowing they don't have much of a say in
who they are or who they'll become
being in good physical shape having high
intelligence and achieving success
are generally easy and aren't that
impressive so people feel a void of
motivation in doing much of anything
mostly everyone is diplomatic with each
other and conflict is almost inexistent
so the majority of people are fairly
bored with nothing to talk about
there is very little risk of illness or
early death so no one really cares to
appreciate what they have
essentially no one has any form of
anxiety ocd add
high anger sadness or anything alike so
much of the arts lose their luster
life is so perfect it flatlines
and people are now soaking in this
nothingness longer than the human brain
has ever been equipped to deal with
frantic the world begins to crumble and
people begin to search for ways to
reverse the effects of genetic
engineering
in her late hundreds now christie
wonders how this could be
how she could have been so wrong how
could a perfect world be
so imperfect christy was one of if not
the smartest and most virtuous
well-intended individuals to ever cross
humanity
she dedicated her life to changing the
world and making it a better place
an ideal utopic version of itself where
health problems were a thing of the past
where pain and suffering were a thing of
the past where aging and early death
were a thing of the past
and where peace health long life and
happiness could be a thing of the
present
and future she thought she had done it
everyone thought she had done it
and in essence she did do it but here
she was witnessing the world collapse
back in on itself
and in this moment she realized what she
had missed even in her success of
removing everything that appeared to be
conflict
the best she could really do was create
new conflict
that nature always had the last say and
had a funny way of making sure things
stayed interesting
that perhaps no matter what she did or
whoever would have inevitably done it
after her
everything was to return to the same
fundamental balance of good and bad
conflict and resolution happiness and
suffering
that the world upside down is really the
same world just at a different angle
in this moment christie understood it
was not that her efforts were a waste
she was the person for the job and she
did what she should have done and she
did everything right
except one thing she missed the point
thank you for watching if you found
enjoyment and value in this video
please give it a thumbs up share your
thoughts in the comments below
and if you are not already be sure to
subscribe to our channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience
life with clarity and wonder